welcome into the show everybody I have
to say I'm glad that this impeachment
saga is over I think I probably speak
for lots of people right now I and I put
so much effort into covering the
impeachment thing on my show that it was
getting exhausting and that's why I'm
that's why I'm grateful and buy so much
effort I mean that I almost completely
ignored it I mean I put in almost zero
effort and covering it which I actually
considered to be perhaps my greatest
professional achievement ignoring
impeachment this entire time and the
greatest kindness that I could have
possibly bestowed upon you the audience
so you're welcome for that Trump is now
acquitted of course as a result that was
absolutely insured from the very
beginning of this extremely pointless
spectacle the only person to vote for
conviction of course was Mitt Romney
only person in his in Trump's party to
vote for conviction I should say was
Mitt Romney along with every single
Democrat a decision by Romney that I
don't personally find especially
objectionable I know that I know that
I'm I'm somewhat maybe not entirely
alone but I know probably most people
don't feel that way at least on the
right
I think Mitt Romney did what he thought
was the right thing to do and that's
what he's supposed to do he's supposed
to follow your own conscience and and
and judge these things according to your
own according to your own judgment the
idea that he did it for some
self-serving reason is I think plainly
ridiculous even though I disagree with
him but considering he probably
guaranteed he's gonna be voted out of
office and he's now persona non grata in
his own party I'm not saying that makes
them a hero so I think we have two
versions of Mitt Romney that are being
put forward now by either side you have
Mitt Romney this scums scoundrel coward
traitor
and then you have Mitt Romney the the
the the knight in shining armor the hero
and that's coming from the left and of
course the irony here is that these are
the very same people that when he was
running for president 2012 said that he
was racist and sexist with his binders
full of women and so on and so forth so
we
that's hypocritical and and and and we
know that it'll change on a dime the
moment that Mitt Romney does something
they don't like so we understand all of
that my point though is I don't really
think he's either of those things I
don't think he's a hero but the
accusation that he's a coward or an
opportunity an opportunist is
preposterous unless I completely
misunderstand what the word opportunism
means because I don't know what the
opportunity is here for him other than
he's ruined his own his own his at least
the latest iteration of his political
career in any case that's the end of it
and I'm very happy for it to be over and
we can all move on as I will and there's
a lot to discuss today but before I do I
want to tell you about my friends over
at noon look it's good to take care of
other people obviously think about other
people that's what that's what
selflessness is all about but it's gonna
be hard for you to take care of other
people if you're not taking care of your
own health and wellness first and that's
what Noom is here for because everyone
is different Numa just to your lifestyle
they teach you the psychology behind the
decisions that you make and then they
help you keep track of everything from
workouts and steps to analyzing your
diet and recommending healthy recipes so
they've got it all they've got all the
points covered here new mall so connects
you with a personally assigned goal
specialist Noom gives you the tools and
you just have to decide to change your
life for the better they're gonna
they're gonna help you do it but you
have to first make that decision neumes
been great for me personally and the app
has been a lifesaver because my health
my health goals have really been sort of
broad in that and want to get healthier
I want to be healthy I want to feel
healthier it's very important and one of
my challenges in that regard has always
been keeping track and keeping organized
keeping track of what I'm doing and and
Numis help me with that a lot based in
psychology Noom teaches you why you do
the things you do and empowers you with
the tools you need to break bad habits
and replace them with better ones
because that's really what it's all
about that's that's that's I think if
you can manage to do that if you could
just form good healthy habits then that
it's almost game set match right there
and that's the biggest challenge is
getting out of those bad habits and into
good ones and that's why you need new
you don't have to change it all in one
day so
all steps make big progress sign up for
your trial today at noon and oom calm /
waltz what do you have to lose visit
Noom calm / walls to start your trial
today that's n om calm / Walsh well if
we go back to very ancient history here
way back to - a period of history that
archeologists are just now discovering
and uncovering and learning about that
would be this past Tuesday the State of
the Union address during his State of
the Union address on Tuesday night
President Trump called for a ban on late
term abortions played that clip
yesterday on the show this plea was made
all the more vivid and powerful by the
presence of a two-year-old girl in the
audience who was born at 22 weeks
gestation and I thought that was a great
illustration of what we're talking about
here when you're when we're talking
about late term abortions we're talking
about aborting this child who was born
at 22 weeks which is now viable medical
advances have made pregnancies quote
viable well before the 3rd trimester and
there's no reason to think that this
trend toward early and early or
viability won't continues this is yet
another example of the way that
pro-abortion people are anti science and
anti medical advancement of course the
argument for banning late term abortion
is morally unassailable there is no
clump of cells dodged available to the
defender of this practice babies in the
second trimester are at least the size
of an adult's hand so we're not talking
about a microscopic embryo okay we're
talking about a child you know that's at
least that long and it despite what
probe orts would would like to imagine
like us to imagine of this microscopic
tiny infant assimil little thing no and
midway through the second trimester they
could be safely delivered with all of
their limbs intact attacked and other
recognizable human features abortions at
this stage are therefore necessarily
brutal the the cervix is in
this as I say it's brutal so I'm some
content warning here but I think it's
important for us to understand exactly
how these these these procedures these
quote procedures are done so I'm going
to explain it if you don't already know
and if you don't want to hear an
explanation you're welcome to mute the
show for the next minute the cervix is
pried open the amniotic fluid around the
child is sucked out the victim the child
is then ripped apart limb by limb with
something called a sofa clamp which is a
which is a long clamp almost looks like
a long pair of pliers with with a
sharpened edge with little teeth that
allowed to attach itself to the limbs of
the child and the child is ripped apart
while still alive okay
third nuts second trimester this is what
Donald Trump says we should ban third
trimester abortions even more barbaric a
poison needle is stabbed through the
mothers abdomen into the baby's skull
now humans at this stage obviously have
fully developed fully functioning
nervous systems so this is agonizingly
painful for the child just imagine how
it would he'll feel for you to be
stabbed in the head with a poison needle
that's how it will feel for the child
there's no effort made whatsoever to
limit the child's suffering because such
efforts would acknowledge the humanity
of or at least the life of the child
which is something the abortion industry
can't do and then the mother and after
the child dies the mother is forced to
carry the the dead baby around in her
womb for two days at which point she
will deliver the corpse and they hope in
the abortion office but oftentimes it
ends it ends up happening in a bathroom
at a hotel or something where they're
staying in some cases though the baby
survives the initial injection and so
has to be given another now I want you
to think about the pain that child is in
for the two days after he's been stabbed
with the poison needle still alive
suffering in agony and then two days
later poison again
unless of course you have a Gosnell
situation in which case the baby would
just be delivered alive and then killed
at that point which by the way is what
Ralph Northam was famously infamously
advocating for I described all of that
because number one this is happening in
the world and we should know about it
it's happening in our country not just
the world and I don't think we have the
right to turn away from it and say oh I
don't want to hear about that that's
that's hard to hear yeah it is hard to
hear that's the point how hard do you
think it is to go through for the child
but also this is what went this is what
Donald Trump is trying to ban but the
abortion industry's minions in the media
can't accept any restrictions on
abortion at all and lacking any
ethically sound argument in favor of
literally tearing viable children apart
limb from limb they resort to lies that
are so so absolutely shameless that
they'd be funny if not for the subject
matter in response to Trump's comments
last night a number of abortion
advocates went on social media or two
nights ago rather went on social media
and and and spread the the bizarre claim
that there's no such thing as late term
abortion late term abortion is quote not
a thing is what abortion advocates
prominent abortion advocates on social
media we're saying this it would not be
any crazier or more delusional for me to
rebut Elizabeth Warren's billionaires
are evil shtick by claiming that
billionaires don't exist it's it's the
same kind of thing on the contrary late
term abortions are most certainly a
thing even estimates and liberal
publications tell us that this quote
very rare read existent procedure
accounts for quote only 1.3 percent of
abortions this was in I think the
Guardian had an article about it liberal
publication in the context of advocating
for abortion is how it's only 1.3
percent
okay well 1.3 percent of abortions that
amounts to over 5,000 babies every
single year that are ripped apart limb
from limb 5,000 now I want you to think
about how we react when there's a school
shooting and nine kids are killed let's
say or 10 or 12 it's horrific it's evil
it's terrible it's a tragedy it's all of
those things we react exactly as we
should to it my point is though 5,000 I
think about a mass attack a mass
slaughter or some kind of kill 5,000
people we wouldn't see that as such a
small number it's only small in
comparison to the gargantuan body count
that the abortion industry racks up
every year it's owned its that's the
only reason it seems well the fact that
that's a small number only tells you it
tells you a lot more about the total
number of abortions and how large that
number is than it does about the the
actual number of late-summer abortions
now also rape and incest account for
less than one percent of abortions yet
pro-abortion people try to bring every
abortion discussion back to this
minority of cases well you can't have it
both ways either the one percent of
cases are relevant or they aren't the
other lie that is only slightly less
egregious is that these abortions are
only carried out to save the mother's
life life yet even former abortionist
and and current OBGYNs have come out in
the past and said that this is simply
not true there's no such thing as a
life-saving abortion to borrow a phrase
that is not a thing
it is never necessary to kill a viable
baby in order to save his mother's life
how could it be if there's a potentially
fatal complication with the pregnancy
the child needs to come out of the
mother but he could be simply delivered
in fact either away the child has to be
delivered alive or dead the only thing
you're doing with an abortion is you're
adding in an extra step of killing the
child before you deliver him there is no
reason why
that could have any medical value for
the mother in reality late late term
abortions can happen because the mother
decides she doesn't want the child they
can happen for the same reason that
earlier term abortions happen these are
not all extreme situations the procedure
quote-unquote is it is extreme extremely
brutal but it's not always that some
extreme position that the mother's bent
and finds herself in is what leads to
the late term abortion that's not the
case it could just be that she she
decides at 25 weeks that she wants she
doesn't have a kid things have changed
in her life she loses a job she loses a
relationship okay those certainly can be
reasons and there are plenty of in in
those 5000 every year a not small number
of them are going to be situation like
that and then there gonna be other
situations where let's say the child has
some serious ailment or disability of
some kind or we're often told that you
know these late term abortions only
happen when the child's gonna die anyway
well it's simply not true that that
accounts for all or even a majority of
cases but that does happen sometimes but
killing a person because he's disabled
or because he's going to die anyway is
is is not medically necessary that's not
medicine and if we call that medicine if
we call that a medical procedure then we
have ventured fully into eugenics
territory and the implications extend
far beyond the womb you know you simply
can't call that the medical treatment
you know it is it's a mercy killing is
what it is and that's a euphemism and in
a cell in itself and I hate that phrase
but if you're looking for a euphemism
that's at least closer to the reality
it's not medical treatment it's mercy
killing
and go ahead and advocate for that
advocate for the quote mercy killing of
of disabled children advocated for if
you want you're not gonna be alone in I
mean there's there's a long history of
eugenics even in this country and back
100 years ago the people who advocated
for eugenics were a lot more open about
it and they would have an and did
Margaret Sanger being one of them come
out and explicitly advocate for it and
say no these these people they're their
lives aren't worth anything it's not
worth living so we should just kill them
you're you're you're arguing for the
same thing you're just using different
words so you may as well confront what
your position actually is and see if you
can stomach it no matter how you look at
it the talking points offered by the
pro-abortion side are ridiculously false
President Trump is right to call for a
ban on this barbarity
and I think all decent people in the
country agree with him and that's really
what it comes down to more to talk about
but a quick note from our good friends
at Rock Auto you know it can be
obviously nobody likes having problems
with their cars and we've as I mentioned
before we've gone through this recently
with both of our cars because bad things
happen in pairs when it comes to cars
happen in bundles really have one
problem leads to another leads to
another and it can be you know it can be
a pain to go to the auto parts store and
deal with that and that's why
rockauto.com is such a great option that
I've been using a lot rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil new carpet matter what
kind of car we're dealing with whether
it's a classic car your daily driver
that you you go around in you can get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate even for
someone like me and remember when you go
to the auto parts store most the time
they don't have what you're looking for
anyway they're gonna have to order it
online why even go through all that go
to rockauto.com for their amazing
selection reliably
prices all the parts your car will ever
need rockauto.com go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck right walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so that
they know that I sent you okay here's a
story this is a story all right reading
from bbc.com says Jameela Jamil has
announced she is quote queer after
receiving criticism for being cast in a
new LGBT interest show u.s. broadcaster
HBO announced on Tuesday that the
actress and model will be a judge on its
new unscripted voguing contest legendary
I confess I have no idea what voguing is
the news prompted an online backlash
from people who said the good place star
was not representative of the black
LGBTQ LGBT community that prompted her
to issue a statement addressing her
sexuality opening with twitter is brutal
she explained that she identified as
queer and had previously struggled to
discuss the topic because it's not easy
within the South Asian community to be
accepted she mentioned that nobody in
her family was openly out and that quote
it's also scary as an actor to openly
admit your sexuality especially when
you're already a brown female in your
30s yes I'm sure it's really scary to be
in the LGBT community in Hollywood right
Jamil went on this is absolutely not how
I wanted to come out and adding that
she's logging off of Twitter oh and hold
on they actually explain what voguing is
all right it says voguing is a genre of
dance that originated in New York in the
late 1980s it was founded by black and
Latino LGBT people many of whom were
disowned by their families for their
sexuality and gender it came to
mainstream attention through Madonna's
1990 hit vogue and the accompanying
video as well as the documentary Paris
is burning okay hold on a second but
first of all Madonna is not in the LGBT
community is she not as far as I know
and so she's the one who started this
voguing thing and now you're not
allowing so it was started by a straight
woman and now a straight woman isn't
allow
to be involved in it or not started by
straight well it was popularized okay it
was brought into mainstream attention
through a straight woman and now we're
saying if you're straight you're not
allowed in alright so there's a lot
that's still mysterious here and maybe
it would be cleared up if I if I kept
reading but I've lost interest I don't
understand why you need to be gay to go
voguing are you telling me that I can't
vogue I could get up and vogue right now
if I wanted to it's it's one of my
greatest passions after I learned about
it ten seconds ago in any case the
upshot here is is that
this Hollywood actress was getting
criticized for the crime of hosting a
show while straight she was being
attacked for not being gay and so she
came out and said oh you know what
funny thing actually turns out I am gay
or not gay but quote queer this this
actually gives me an idea for what I
might do the next time I'm being
attacked I get attacked all the time as
you know and maybe this is a good way
out of it but notice the brilliance of
this move by um by Jamil here she comes
out as queer right not gay but queer so
what does queer mean well nobody really
knows it's entirely undefined it means
whatever you want it to mean basically
so if you can claim that the LGBTQ now I
believe Q can also mean questioning so
you could be query can be questioning
like ever ends anyone can claim that
there's no way to confirm it you could
just wear that label and go about your
day like you were before don't change
anything so it was a smart move and
nobody's allowed to question her
self-identification just like when a man
comes out as a woman you can't question
it it's a checkmate they win that's all
it is to it
notice also here how my my victim
pyramid is illustrated once again
remember on the left victimhood is
currency right whoever has the most
victim token wins but the uber victims
the chief victims those who have the
greatest wealth of victim currency by
far are the LGBTQ folks women even
ethnic minority
are beneath the LGBT people in the
hierarchy so Jamil is a woman ethnic
minority a feminist she was just you may
recognize the name because we talked
about on the show last month she was
just last month bragging about her
abortion she was shouting her abortion
so she's an ethnic minority woman who
shouts her abortions you would think
that that would get her to the top but
no she still is beneath the LGBT camp
it doesn't earn her enough identity
token points to even host a dancing
competition on HBO because the LGBTQ
camp decided that she shouldn't be
allowed to do that and what they say
goes on the left if they say it that's
it they're in charge if they say you're
not allowed to do that that's it if they
say we're gonna do this we're gonna do
if they say to women hey these these
dudes are gonna be coming into your
locker rooms now that's just how it is
they're gonna be on your sports teams -
no no and it no shut up
shut up you're not allowed to protest
you big it shut up they can do that the
LGBTQ of you can do that they can they
can they can talk to women like that and
they do talk to women like that so what
does what does Jamil do she says oh
funny story this is the problem that the
left is running into on one hand
everything comes down to identity
politics right all that matters is the
demographic you fall into that's going
to determine that will determine what
you're allowed to do what you're allowed
to say what you're allowed to think the
reality shows you're allowed to host it
determines everything it determines what
kind of person you are it determines the
value of yourself as a person but
they've also made identity into this
nebulous hazy thing they blurred the
lines of distinction relativized
identity thrown thrown out all the
objective categories leading now to a
mad dash to the top of the hierarchy
because anyone could be there all you
have to do to be considered a part of
any particular category is simply say
that you're in that
category and that's it no other steps
required so now everyone can say they're
LGBT and the hierarchy becomes very
top-heavy so now it's become sort of a
ruling class without anybody to rule
Kings and and drag queens without any
subjects you've got a bunch of pharaohs
and no peasant class no slaves to
maintain the pyramid which is quite a
predicament except you still have white
men for the most part okay good we could
still all agree that white men like
myself are scum problem though is that a
white man like myself I'm all the way
that at the bottom of the pyramid I
could in one fell swoop
leapfrog all the way to the top just
with a simple phrase I'm a woman I say
that and now I'm at the top so even even
the the most reliable you would think
you would think that at least they can
they can rely on having the white men
down there that they can all turn in
hate even that's not so reliable because
we can escape this this ghetto any
moment just by saying oh you know what
turns out I'm a woman yeah oh I don't
look like a woman I don't have any of
the parts of a woman no I've never I've
never said I was a woman before it
doesn't matter doesn't matter it's got
to take my word for it I'm afraid
we're gonna go to emails in a second but
first you know what a year this month
has been in the election race is
unfortunately just getting started the
best way to stay informed and on top of
all of it is is to become a daily wire
member with 20% off of your membership
and I think you really need to because
things move so quickly these days that
you need you need someone to tell you
what's going on so 20% off of all daily
water memberships when using promo code
dwu 2020 members get our articles add
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now ben Shapiro's election
insight op-eds
you also get as well plus our new all
access to your gets you into live online
Q&A discussions with ben shapiro andrew
clave and myself Michael Knowles plus
our sites are sites other writers
special guests as well so if you have a
question you can get an answer but first
you got to download The Daily wire app a
member exclusive so you can get push
notifications straight to your phone
again that's promo code DW 2020 for 20%
off trust me you don't want to miss it
alright this is from Rodolfo Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com says hi Matt I really
need your advice on how to navigate the
situation my sister who was in with my
sister who's in a same-sex relationship
whose partner conceived a baby through
IVF I assumed before they broke the news
to us she asked me what my thoughts were
I calmly explained how the baby is
entitled to a father and mother and how
the two contribute different needs to
the child she refused to acknowledge
that they provide different needs and
kept insisting as long as they have to
as long as they have loving parents
they're fine
I completely forgot to insert how the
extra frozen fertilized eggs are human
beings and deserving of life but now
that her partner has been blessed with a
child I don't know how to go about
day-to-day interactions do I attend the
baby shower pretending I approve of this
do I tell my daughter do I pretend I
approve and other families around thank
you for all you do rodolfo well what you
tell your daughter really depends on how
old she is and I don't think you
mentioned that if she's very young if
she's like my kids age then I would not
tell her anything because she wouldn't
understand it anyway
as for approving of it look obviously
you're gonna accept the child right and
you're gonna love the child as a niece
or nephew you're not gonna like a spurn
the child and say I know you're not
gonna do that
and you love your sister even if you
don't approve of her choices so I think
on a day to day basis your your approval
is kind of irrelevant right you don't
have to act like you approve or you
don't approve you just act like they're
family which they are and you go about
your business you aren't going to
ostracize or disown them right I think
we would agree that's not gonna be an
option so and that wouldn't be the right
response at all
so what other option is there but to
love and accept them now when I say
accept okay this word acceptance
can be a problem given that it has such
a broad meaning now to a lot of people
but really accepting someone as a person
and as a family member is not the same
thing as approving of their choices we
tend to think of those things as the
same but they're not so we should accept
our family members accept them in a
sense of love them and embrace them as
family members
that's what acceptance would mean here
it doesn't mean approve of everything
they do which is good because I don't
think anyone has a family where they
approve of everything that everybody in
their family does and that's just not
how families operate so I think all of
us or at least many of us have family
members who have made choices we
disagree with maybe that we strongly
disagree with but unless that choice
makes them a physical danger to you and
your child I think you still treat them
as family because they are I don't think
you should pretend to approve as you say
but the point is 99% of what you do with
your family and how you treat them has
nothing to do with approval or
disapproval anyway so it really doesn't
come up hope that's not a not trying to
dodge your question but I think when you
were asking mainly what are you doing a
day-to-day basis and she's she's your
sister that's it that's what you do on a
day-to-day basis this is from Abigail
Abigail says hey Matt I have an
incredibly important question for you in
fact it may be the most important
question you've ever answered so please
don't answer it hastily my reputation as
a college student and relationship with
my peers depends on this is the correct
pronunciation of ramen noodles ramen or
Raymond well I guess I already answered
that didn't I
who says Raymond noodles Raymond noodles
is that is that a thing I hope you're
not in the Raymond noodle camp Raymond
noodle sounds like the name of a of a
party clown or something that's no it's
definitely ramen noodles and if you were
in the Raymond camp Abigail I'm afraid
to say that
you deserve to have your reputation
destroyed and to lose all your friends
for it infractions such as that this is
from Ian says why can't you support our
president without throwing in your
little insults you said you liked his
State of the Union great why did you
need to go on about how he's no good off
the script chump off the script is
exactly why why what won him the
presidency so your point makes no sense
it seems like you try to play both sides
of the fence sometimes throwing in anti
conservative opinions to appeal to the
left hey anything for ratings and
acceptance I guess it seems like you're
really a nevertrump or at heart and you
try to disguise it and that's too bad
because it never Trump errs are grifters
and cowards I'd hate to think the same
about you but you make me wonder and I'm
not the only one well in first of all I
didn't say anything yesterday that could
possibly be construed as an insult of
Donald Trump I was applauding his
performance it's my opinion that he's
better on the script and off that his
rambling routine on the campaign trail
and his tweets are at best kind of stale
at this point and at worse extremely
off-putting to a lot of people that's my
view and I've been very consistent about
that this entire time not an insult
though criticism yeah but not all
criticisms are insults and anyway insult
or not how is that anti conservative its
anti conservative now to criticize a
Republican president so the entirety of
the conservative cause comes down to
your personal feelings about a dude a
guy the president he is now the
embodiment of everything that it means
to be conservative and all you have to
do all you have to do to be conservative
is just to agree with him all the time
at about about everything is that your
position now I I'm being someone
intentionally obtuse here because I know
that is exactly the position that that
some quote conservatives have and have
had this entire time with regards to
Trump but I find it to be ridiculous and
pathetic and I also think that at least
for me if being a conservative means
anything one of the most crucial one of
the most crucial aspects of being
conservative is to have a healthy
skepticism of the gut
and which means being critical of the
government and not being afraid to
criticize the government Donald Trump
runs the government so he's part of that
so my point is in my view to say that
you shouldn't criticize or even insult
quote-unquote the president is one of
the most anti conservative
unconservative positions you could
possibly take and let me just clarify
something for you just so you know you
thought that you say that I throw in
these little anti conservative opinions
as you put it and from the sound of it
you mean more than just the Trump stuff
you are saying that the times when I
venture from standard accepted right
wing talking points I'm doing it for
ratings and appeal and acceptance and so
on and you say that never Trump errs
whatever that means whoever they are are
also in it for personal gain okay just
so you know in my position as I guess a
conservative media person there is
nothing at all to be personally gained
from from straying from the party line
there's nothing to be gained from that
now unless you have a full scale
conversion to leftism
and you decide to start parroting
left-wing talking points across the
board as some former conservatives like
Jen Rubin have actually done under Trump
now if you do that it's still kind of a
gamble because there's no there's no
guarantee you're gonna be accepted by
the left but if you do that then yes
that could be a calculation for personal
gain might earn you a spy gig on MSNBC
or CNN as their token quote reasonable
conservative fine but there is no
business advantage no opportunistic
benefit at all to doing anything other
than parroting right wing talking points
or left wing talking points you could
choose one or the other but if you
choose option you know C D E or F er or
X or Y or Z you know if you go anywhere
besides those two options there is no
real
benefit to it others then you're just
being honest about what you think so
a and B right parrot right wing talking
points left wing talking words in my
business those are the safest and most
profitable things outside of that
however far you venture outside of that
you sacrifice money and ratings the most
profitable thing for a conservative
media person by far is to be a die-hard
Trump fan to never criticize him always
defend them and to just sort of put your
finger in the air see which way the wind
is blowing with your base and talk about
popular conservative topics and give
popular conservative opinions don't
don't go too far right don't go left
don't go in the middle don't go off and
that too right don't go in any
directions except just right there in
that lane and if you if you have an
audience as a conservative and you stay
in that Lane you're guaranteed a job in
perpetuity you're guaranteed an audience
you're guaranteed money it's a good
business profitable business anyway my
point is anyone who does anything other
than that anything other than that there
could only be one reason why they do it
and that is they're just being honest
now does does that make that's kinda
like I was saying about Mitt Romney not
that I'm comparing myself to him but am
I saying that when I stray outside of
the normal talking points I'm doing
something heroic and selfless no you
know I'm still doing fine for myself and
taking care of my family it's not like
I'm it's not like I'm making some huge
sacrifice not at all
but I just want to be just so you
understand I think there are a lot of
people don't understand how this works
you know saying that someone who strays
outside of the talking points is doing
it for the money would be like saying
that a person became a trash collector
because
they're a germophobe or they got into
social work for the money
you know I mean it's it's the accusation
is exactly the opposite of the reality
okay if you want to know who the
potential grifters and opportunists are
among conservative media figures all you
have to do is look at the people who
never ever ever challenged their own
audience and are always just right in
line with what most people think on the
right
everything is appealing to the crowd
everything is you know everything is
crowd pleasing all the time look at
those people now I'm not saying that all
of them are grifters an opportunist I
don't know I can't see inside their
heart it's possible that their views
really do just happen to line up with
what most of the audience wants to hear
extremely unlikely but it's possible I
can't say for sure but those are gonna
be the potential that's where you want
to look for suspected grifting you want
to look over there okay all right what
else here I wanted to tell you you know
back in July a friend of Daily wire bill
Whittle
hosted this excellent four-part series
podcast called the Apollo 11 what we saw
and I really enjoyed it I think it got a
lot of people loved it
speaking of getting away from normal
talking points this is something
entirely different it's not politics and
this was bill taking you back in time
living through it experiencing the space
age again now bill has a new season of a
show all about the Cold War be sure to
check out the Cold War what we saw not
only is it a very compelling story but
it's also an important reminder of what
it is like to live in back you know in
those times and to live through that
with no future which is where we all end
up if the far-left
makes it to the presidency as the host
bill captures what it was like to live
through major events like the Berlin
Airlift the Korean War the Cuban Missile
Crisis space race and a story ties all
these milestones together to create this
picture of the apocalypse that never
happened the story is so well told and
the setting is so brilliantly
descriptive that as you go through these
events you start to understand
the battle not only for capitalism but
for civilization itself they've released
two episodes of this 12 part series
already so it's a perfect time to go
catch up just go to daily wire.com slash
cold war and start listening to this
incredibly important story that's daily
wire.com slash cold war all right one
more emails from Henry says hey Matt I
take the issue I take issue with the
idea that there that there are not any
restrictions or that there are any
restrictions on free speech you
mentioned that you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater in this case it's not
the speech that's illegal it's the
inciting of a stampede that's the
problem in the case where the girl
convinced her boyfriend to kill himself
it's not the word she said that need to
be restricted it's the act of causing
someone to kill themselves
that's illegal same thing with Charles
Manson you could repeat every word that
Charles Manson ever said and you would
have the right because you have a right
to free speech however you don't have
the right to cause someone to commit
murder the slippery slope that I'm
afraid of is that once you concede that
there are some restrictions of free
speech why can't we also restrict hate
speech for example I'm from Canada where
we have hate speech laws and comedians
get fined for making offensive jokes and
this is where I think you will
inevitably end up if you believe there
are restrictions to free speech
anyway I think you understand my point
well Henry I think you're trying to play
a semantic game to get around the
reality that we do and must restrict
speech and we always have but you say
it's not it's not speech that's the
problem
but the inciting of a stampede or the
brainwashing of people to kill people or
you know or what have you
yes but how is the stampede incited how
are the people brainwashed with speech
so this would be like if I murdered
someone and you said no it's not the
shooting that's illegal
but the causing of someone to be dead
yeah well that's a distinction without a
difference it's true that shooting
people isn't always illegal you could be
shooting in self-defense but shooting
someone to kill them is you know to
murder them is illegal so that that the
the right to shoot as it were is
restricted for obvious reasons just
right the speech is restricted not that
I'm comparing saying words to shooting
someone but yeah I think hopefully you
get my point and it must be restricted
in in the situations I described and in
other city in in many other situations
besides now I understand your revulsion
to and discomfort with the idea that
free speech can be restricted because
that means as you seem to realize that
there actually isn't anything such thing
as free speech not in an absolute sense
and if it's not if speech is not
absolutely free then it's not really
free at all if we're not talking about
freedom in an absolute sense then why
are we even using the word it seems like
a it seems like a word that misses the
point right and yeah that is the
uncomfortable truth but its truth
nonetheless free speech is as we've been
talking about a very imprecise phrase
more of a symbolic phrase not one that
can be taken totally literally and that
goes for all freedoms really because
none of them are absolutely absolute
because anyone could think of exceptions
you have the freedom of religion I
believe in that absolutely but or not
absol I believe I certainly believe in
that but what if you belong to the
ancient Aztec religion and you what you
want to perform human sacrifices well
you better get a job at Planned
Parenthood otherwise you're not gonna be
allowed to do that now you could say all
you want oh well that's not really
restricting freedom of religion that's
different
no it is that's a religion and that's a
religious practice and we're saying you
shouldn't be allowed to do it so it's a
restriction on freedom yes the reason
you can't do it is because it's gonna
kill another person nonetheless it is a
religious practice that we are saying
you cannot do it is a restriction on
religion there's no way around it I know
we want to find ways around it so we
could phrase it a different way or or
maybe start a lot of times when people
will do as though they don't want to
admit that there are restrictions on
freedom so instead they'll say well let
maybe we need to think about the word
religion maybe this Aztec religion isn't
really a religion or maybe the
you know we don't want to admit that
laws against slander our restriction on
free speech
so maybe slander isn't really speech
we're you know we try to adjust the word
speech rather than the word free that
doesn't that doesn't work and I don't
think it really convinces anybody I
think we all know the truth now the good
news is that these restrictions on
speech have always been in place it's
never been legal to slander somebody to
libel someone it's never been legal to
tell someone to go kill another person
that's it's never been legal to do those
things and yet we still live in a
country where you can basically go out
and say what you want or at least
express any idea any political idea that
you want at least in this country we do
maybe not in Canada so I don't know if
the free if the slippery slope has
really has really panned out exactly as
you're saying which doesn't mean we
shouldn't be vigilant I think we still
have to be vigilant because there are
people who would like to infringe even
on our ability to express political
views and that sort of thing and that
certainly is a problem but I don't think
I think we have to meet those challenges
I don't think we meet those challenges
by pretending to be free speech
absolutist when free speech absolutism
is nonsensical ok we'll leave it there
thanks for the thanks for the email I
did have another email as I was going to
read I think I'll save it for tomorrow
but somebody well somebody writes me
with I often get just like the one from
Rodolfo I get I get questions from
people about family dilemmas where they
want my opinion and on one hand I'm not
sure my opinion really means anything I
don't know I don't know that I have any
insight that's really gonna be helpful
to people with these situations but I
get the emails anyway someone wrote me
with a dilemma involving their family
that is
certainly the most difficult dilemma
anyone's ever emailed me before and so I
think I was I'm gonna save that for
tomorrow because that's gonna be a
longer conversation and have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there